كنا نتحدث عن يعني مساعدات مقدمه من الامم
المتحده وايضا مساعدات مقدمه من الدول
العربيه الاسيمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الطائرات وصلت الى مطارين داخل اراضي
التركيه لمطار غازيه عنتاب ومطار اضنه
يعتقد بان القوافل يعني تنزيلها وتحميلها
ستستغرق بعض الموافقات يعني الروتينيه من
الطرف التركي تحتاج الى بضع ساعات لتصل
الى معبر باب الهوى ومن ثم ادخالها الى
المناطق المنكوبه في شمال غرب البلاد
وتحديدا الارياف ادلب وحلب
حيث ينتظر يعني تنتظر فرقه الانقاذ بشكل
كبير
محتوى هذه المساعدات هي مساعدات طبيه
وانسانيه المساعدات الطبيه مطلوبه في
المقام الاول ليها المساعدات الانسانيه
وايضا فرق الانقاذ حيث يعتقد بان يعني
المساعدات المقدمه من الدول العربيه
معها يعني فرق انقاذ لمساعده الدفاع
المدني على رفع الانقاض وانتشال
الاشخاص هذه الاناقات سواء كانوا يعني
احياء او حتى سرقوا الحياه